as claiborne approached the stop sticks
he avoided the stop sticks and
intentionally intentionally drove
directly towards trooper may and struck
him with the stolen vehicle
those details tough to hear but tonight
we do understand
more about the incident than killed an
nhp trooper
good evening thanks for joining us here
at five i'm denise valdis and i'm
christian casa as we're getting a closer
look at what happened during last week's
car chase turned shooting
on the i-15 orca mana joins us live near
metro headquarters with all the details
orcam
[Music]
well christian and denise our community
continues to feel the loss
of nhp trooper micah may he was killed
last tuesday
during a pursuit on the i-15 and tonight
we're getting our first look at police
footage of that day
now this is newly released police aerial
footage from lvmpd
showing public safety officers chasing a
carjacking suspect
douglas claiborne as he drove
erratically on the i-15
and also on surrounding streets police
say claiborne stole someone's car and
even used a foot long knife
to threaten that person parole and
probation officers noticed the stolen
vehicle
and nhp troopers helped with the pursuit
we're told nhp tried
to stop sticks tried stop stick several
times including when trooper may
laid them down police say claiborne
intentionally hit trooper may
nhp was able to ram the vehicle and stop
claiborne
then a handful of officers opened fire
and officers then observed claiborne
grabbing trooper may's gun
this prompted the officers to fire their
weapons at claiborne
claiborne was struck several times and
he was
subsequently pronounced deceased on
scene
a metro helicopter then arrived on the
i-15 to transport trooper may to umc
unfortunately trooper may passed away
two days later
last thursday now there will be a vigil
to honor trooper
trooper may tomorrow starting at six
that will be at police memorial park
and everyone is invited to attend
reporting live tonight from metro
headquarters orca mana 8 news now